hello everybody welcome to another night
of chess on psychology
hope you are having a good day so far my
week has been going pretty well
um i got a chance to well
do a lot of fun stuff packing unpacking
new house a lot of new chess material to
look at too
and while i was just scrolling through
some of my games
i came upon two games that i had that i
was
i had an advantage against higher-risk
opponents
and i kind of
didn't exactly use it the way i should
have
so ergo the name of today's
um lecture how much does material matter
and that's something that i struggled
with quite a lot
during my chess career that's always
like
you're like pawn up how much does it
mean you have a
high you have more extreme one more
exchange uh does it mean
you're winning
can your opponent still get away with it
so that's something that i'm gonna try
and
show you today also i'm sitting in
my coach's office alejandro ramirez
since
nobody is coming to use the chest room
in station university i'm just sitting
here
using his chair so thank you alejandra
um anyways let's get back to the chess
of it
also let me get my chat activated i'm
not sure
where it is there we go all right
so um the first game that i want to show
you
is a game i had against anna muzichok
back in 2016. um 2016 was a very
successful year for me also 2015.
in 2017 i moved to san plus university
and i kind of shifted gears
from being just from being like a
full-time chess player to a full-time
student
slash chess player so um
we kind of i thought it would be
interesting
time to look at that so back in 2016
i was invited to play in a closed round
robin
event in germany munich where i actually
did my ted talk last summer too
and this tournament was called beautiful
minds and
they were some really great chess
players
and me i believe i was the youngest of
them
uh there were the music sisters there
was like
nigel short there there was um there
were like
one or two 2700s so i was
um playing some big monsters
and i got a really good experience out
of it and kind of fun fact
right after this tournament on april
uh on december 3rd i did my sids and i
got the score that i
kind of wanted and i came to slough so
back to the chest of it
instead of the history of it um i
did a little bit of preparation before
the game because
the games were kind of condensed but
since this was a round ribbon
i had uh i hadn't i had some idea that's
who i was but i play
and about the color we kind of um
figured it out after the first round
well um
when the pairings for the first round
were drawn
so i did i did take a quick look at
what anna was playing and um this
uh this variation the
yeah yeah exactly this is silly thank
you
but no this um
it has it depends on how you play it but
i sometimes like to play knight d5 early
on but i'm a big fan of bishop g5
and i looked at different variations
like here
um well my d5 is kind of a given uh the
switch nick of defense kind of feels
like an attack but anyways
um kind of there are different
variations you can try with c3 you can
drive a c4
there are some sacrifices on b5 but i've
taken a look on those two you could also
try to take
and then try with knight d oops
taking with the queen is not so good
because you lose tempo
but still um you take over d5 and these
are also some interesting lines
but um just looking at it from
let's say somebody who has no idea
what's going on at this position
you're clearly gonna see that this um
well the blacks position has
some holes in it and this outpost on d5
is something that
with white we can try to use but at the
same time
it's not so easy because black has some
activity in the queen side
and um white could also
be getting have some issues with
uh center like if black is to play d5
then white's having some issues
so and yeah good thinking fragrance yes
i do remember
that nega's book did have a
recommendation
on this too i had some i looked at it
way
before that too 2011 with um elsand when
he was my coach
and um i thought it was interesting but
i like to play this a little bit more
positionally so i
usually play this line either c3 or c4
and in this game especially since it was
a rapid tournament
i kind of wanted to just give c4 a
a bit of more um
devotion so after c4 there are
different lines b4 is the main line and
after knight c2
um there there's gonna be black's gonna
castle play a5
trying to do bishop g5 and ideally try
to do something with f5
that's what black is trying to do
white is still using this d5 square and
blocking this d4 square so that's good
but there are some issues with the
bishop on f1 so sometimes we might want
to just
get this bishop out with h4 and bishop
it's trees so yeah those are some of the
ideas that we could try and
do and whoa the sport has so many errors
right now all right
so that's like a general overview of
the middle game that we could be facing
in this game
but anyways uh anna didn't play b4
she just went for 94. so 94
the first thing you're gonna notice is
oh well can i take this
so my first question to you guys what
should we do can we take on b5
should we take on b5
if not what do you want to take on f6
i'm getting a lot of no's well if you
don't want to take on b5 then what else
do you want to do
all right i can see
well if you're trying to play knight c2
you have to keep in mind that this queen
a5 is also coming up
so if you buy knight c2 um
well there's
pokemon fast now there's b4 but what if
something like bishop g4
going after the queen if you play queen
d2
can i go for bishop 35 yeah the bishops
are getting way too activated no
i am not a biggest fan of trying knight
c2
if there was b4 then yes knight c2 makes
kind of more sense because then you have
something
clear target to go after but in this
specific
situation i wouldn't really recommend
knight c2
but hold on why do you guys not like
taking on b5
if uh if black takes back well that's
great we're just gonna take knight takes
b5
if knight takes whoa this is amazing
just take with bishop
and bishop d7 doesn't really work
because of the b6 square
or well actually not even b6 square can
i just take on f6
or can i just castle and start pushing
these guys
yeah i think
yeah i think this might be a little bit
better
but sorry not a little bit better this
much this is much better for
white so black should not take that back
with the pawn
also ah i was kind of hoping it would
stay
on the names in the chat
lovely well i'm going to disable that
for a second
all right there we go it's a little too
hopeful um
instead of castles might be six
um so you are saying
if take well knight b6 also has
had its own problems so we were talking
about take take
take bishop d7 and
i think the issue with knight b6
well i mean actually this i was thinking
if there are any potential
checks but no just no this is still
winning for whites never mind this works
too
yeah um yes you're correct knight b6
is possible but still so
we know that if we take c takes b5 at
xb5 is not the best
choice for black so what else do you
think black could do
well actually try and develop right so
how
huh yes yes about the room this is um
alejandro's office at status
university's chess room so
i've hijacked his office officially and
his chair it's a nice chair
i might actually come here to study more
often
yeah queen i5 is possible but the
problem with queen a5
is that if you play queen a5 right away
i can just play queen d2 and
you can are either forced to exchange
the queens or
um get a can go back and that doesn't
really do any good
so queen a5 is worth considering but
it's not really working right now so
yes bishop v6 is the best one and that's
what ana did too
after bishop e6 i simply just
um took on a6
because well first of all free pawn
um second of all
well now black is trying to create some
threats
with let's say if i just play something
like bishop d3
now black wants to take over here and
give me check
i don't have b4 so i don't really have
queen d2
either because then i have to take this
knight on d5 remember
when the knight was on d5 we could take
on f6 we could try and take on a5 and
give c7 check pick this
up that knight on d5 was great now
without the knight on d5 black is
actually doing pretty well
um there's a question about
queen a5 in the first place um what do
you mean
instead of bishop e6 well we did speak
we didn't mention it
or are you talking like here if here
queen a5
this is also possible but still queen d2
and i still stop all of these threads
so that doesn't really help black either
and
these end games is quite more
comfortable for whites yes the king is
not castle but we don't really need
um castling when the there's no attack
on the king
especially in this position this is a
weakness we are going to
start upon march and the queen side and
i think white's position is more
desirable
so queen a5 would have to be a very
specific situation
anyways so now after take
take take queen a5 check
we already spoke about this we do have
to play queen d2
now in this position um
i think queen d5 was something that was
worth considering
but i think after queen d5 i was
thinking about bishop b5
check and trying to just make my
opponents enough castle and then
castle oops not can't guess soldiers
knight f3 whoops um
can i just do rook f1 uh rook d1
no taking on g2 that's going to be a
huge problem
well maybe not bishop b5 maybe
we could try to deny c2
yeah i think knight c2 might be a chill
way to play this
if you castle then i can take over here
take that this might be an issue
bishop d3 queen takes here
what do you guys think we should do now
so why to move what should we do
the rook is a problem if you play rook
f1 there could be rookie a check king d1
um maybe bishop g5
no nazi does not a blender
well go back to knight c2 but yeah thank
you thank you villa
long castle it's kind of crazy right
if you play bishop g5 i just have f4
this is
pretty cool position
um and long castle the other good thing
about it is that the king
this bishop is covering this crucial um
file so black does can't really attack
my king
you give me two moves i'll play king b1
rook g1 and you're the one who's in
big problem alright uh there was a
question about knight c2
um well here we talked about knight c2
we can't really cast the last white so
that's why you play knight c2 if my
bishop was already on d3 oh believe me i
would have castled
um so i think knight c2
is the best one here and if
take take
castle maybe i can just try to play
queen c4 gotta move your queen maybe d4
my idea is that i want to get my bishop
out without losing this pawn because
when the queen was on d5 queen could
take g2
right um let me go back there's a
question about
bishop c4 um well if take here you play
bishop c4
um no taking on g2 and then knight f3
and i don't see how you can hold this
if you do long castle now there's bishop
g5 no more f4s
because whoops f4 he just takes it
so
yeah i don't think this would this is
pretty lost i don't like this
um she should have traded queens because
she's high rated well
i don't think that's how she thought i
also don't think that's how i think when
i'm
playing with lower right heads i just
try to figure out what the position
needs and try to complicate it so my
opponent makes a mistake
in this position after queen d2 she did
try to complicate the position and she
took rick takes a6
so what do you guys think should we take
this rook
should we just let it be is the trap
keep in mind that if you do take that
work on asics you're not going to be
able to do short castle
pretty much ever since the queen is
cutting my king's way
so what do you think we should do as
white
um how do i understand what the position
needs well basically
if um the easiest way is to try and
detect
what um the weaknesses in the position
and how you can try
and either improve them if you are the
one with the weakness
or how can you try and exploit them if
your opponent has those weaknesses
so right now i think white's biggest
strength is these two pawns so maybe
that's something that we could work on
and try to
um well push
so that's one thing that i was kind of
hoping to achieve during this game
but also yes uh understanding different
and middle games
does really help with your
um understanding of what the position
needs
because a lot of not a lot of the time
but it's different
when you are playing different openings
you understand different
and middle games better and um
you try you kind of figure out
where the pieces belong so
i for one i do know that this night
doesn't belong here so that's something
that i gotta improve
i gotta figure out what to do with my
king so um
those are some of the little things that
you could try and
work around a little uh we could play
something like bishop d3
but this is this one is also falling so
what if queen takes here even if you
take on a6 oh boy
you can just take on g2 still long
castle there's bishop g5 and knight f3
is popping
so this is quite painful
um so we kind of do have to take it over
here
and now what do you think we should do
what shall we do with the king
you knight c2 your knight isn't the
problem
your king is so you gotta figure out
what to do with the king
because even if you play knight c2 now
um isn't there a knight b3
tactically could nope sorry never mind
um maybe bishop g5
because if you take now well your e2 is
an issue
maybe knight e3 now there's knight b3
so can't do 93 maybe queen d1
yeah i don't really i don't really like
this
i prefer not to allow bishop g5 thank
you
fragrance yeah we should do vlog castle
um
i long castle it would have been pretty
interesting because
after lancaster let's say black plays
short castle and then we can try with
king b1
just put the king in a safe position and
we could just go for a queen exchange
now this is a quite comfortable end game
if
black were to take which i doubt but
still if
we got this position yes this knight is
pretty strong but we
are still gonna do our best to start
pushing these palms
so it would be very very comfortable and
that's something that i
didn't do in the game i should have done
this castle
but i didn't so um
in the game i was trying to figure out
how to get this
rook out because my king isn't the
biggest problem the biggest problem is
this rook
yes the king is not very ideal but it's
defended and their center can't
i mean center isn't really open so
i'm not that worried about my king if i
have my rook on like the third rank
i think my king is pretty covered so i
tried with h4
and my idea was to try and get my piece
of my workout
and just try to get something out with
um on the third ring
i did not play f3 just yet
um yeah so that's the thing like we
again
that's the question so how much does
material matter we have
we have more material we have this clear
advantage
long-standing advantage of your
pawn structure and the fact that you
have more material but your opponent is
pretty active and your opponent does
have compensation
so you have to find the
most precise moves the most accurate
moves so
i played h4 which kind of um didn't
really help that cause
anyways after h4 um
she played castle and i finally said
all right enough is enough let's try to
get rid of that mite
what do you think is the best move for
black
if black tanks knight takes c2 oh great
i'll just take that with the queen and
then i'll play queenie two and i'll just
castle but
my p3 doesn't work right now because my
knight on ct is defending my a1 rook
that's a mistake i also made a few moves
ago and i suggest that knight beat you
and the knight doesn't seat you so
there's nothing wrong with suggesting it
as long as you think about it before you
play it
you're making candidate moves you're
trying to see if knight beatry is a
viable candidate move or not
queen c4 is interesting oh rook c8 is
the best one yeah
rick's eight
receiving you are very clear you gotta
move this knight
um rook c1 was also possible but i was
really hoping to keep as much as
my pawns as i could so i
was a little afraid of something like
queen c4
and then i'm having some issues with
both pawns
um this is this is still pretty playable
i should have played king d1
queen takes d5 and try and exchange some
stuff
something like that perhaps
but the biggest mistake i made in this
game
was not making long castle i was still
hopeful that i could like get my king
some cover
around here and still keep the roganish
one i should have
understood that my position needs my
king to be on b1
and i need this recall to also be
activated just because it's behind the
pass bomb doesn't mean it's activated so
that was my biggest mistake in this game
anyways after knight c2 c8 i decided to
take on d4 and get rid of that
very annoying knight now i thought my
position was doing alright
i just thought i should figure out
something with the king again so i could
have
thought about f3 i did think about f3
but i was worried about d3
and now roof c2 coming up so then i
would have to play like rook c1
check um maybe king f1
now e2 is also weak maybe something with
like
bishop e5 or something with h whoops
too much edge h5 so the king has some
room to breathe
yeah i don't really like this i think
black is um doing fine
especially since my rook is also kind of
suffocating
um yeah exactly i was quite skeptical
about
whether or not i should have taken here
but i just didn't want to play rook c1
because of queen c4
and knight e3 also is not very ideal
just because
this bishop jumps to the other side
and yeah and that's really it's not a
happy
picture so after take
take i just went for a4 and my idea was
a4 but it's kind of clear all right
this is this two pawns are my advantage
the rook horses bishop is my advantage
i'm going to start using
these so after
a4 what do you think what do you think
now we should do as white
well be easy that's not completely true
the knight on a3 would have been a hero
if we did long castle
also yes that is true usually on um
especially if the night ends up on e3
and it's not a very pretty sight
so why to move what do you think we
should do here is also
uh i made another mistake inaccuracy
so what do you think is the most
accurate move you don't have that many
moves
so you could start um thinking about
candidate moves
so yeah push a4 bomb that's definitely a
candidate move f3 another candidate move
not true about broken strangest
orchestras seems
very weird what are you trying to do
after this
queen f1 you lose this guy
yeah let's not lose three pieces
i'm also teaching camps in the mornings
so one of my
biggest rules is don't give your
opponents free gifts
we try to do the same over here let's
not give our opponents free gifts
so we do have some candidate moves a5 is
definitely candid move
f3 is definitely candidate move um
when i was looking at this with engine i
got a recommendation for f42
but it's just kind of just to be honest
not really
it doesn't make much sense to me if i'm
gonna play um
because the idea behind f4 is that yes
you are opening
some room with for your kink you're also
taking away square from bishop
and then you might want to push over
here so i
am not f4 feels like a
superhuman move it didn't feel right
just even after looking at it with the
engine so
um we're between a5 and f3
let's try to go a little deeper um if we
play
f if we play a5
the one thing we should be worried about
is rookie a check right
because if we check we have to play king
d1 and then after let's say a5 or
e8 king d1 d3 so a5 for e8
king d1 d3 now what do you want to do
as white
you have to be quite precise because now
rookie 2 is coming
up your queen is having some serious
issues queen c2 is coming up
a lot of stuff are coming up so
um roof c1 there's a queen b3 oopsie
doopsy careful
rook h3 or rook a3
i think those two are something to be
considered
i think the problem of rook h3 is
a steel queen b3 and
then ah yes rookie one
and queen c2 so we can't really do this
rook
h3 so
another another problem of this position
is queen b2
uh queen b3 so these rookie 2 or queen
b3 are the series threats
so you kind of got to play this tricky
tree to stop them
so after rook a3 let's say black simply
takes on d5
what do you think we should do
so why to move what do you think we
should do make sure you think about what
does black want
so i agree we do have to think about
taking on d3
but does taking a does queen g2 worry
you
um i'm not sure about a6
because it takes over here don't know
there's this check
let's say a player he won that check
over there
and then can i throw in another check or
c8 and let me not foresee it maybe
queen c6 you move this guy
and oh yes
take take and queen c2 queen takes b2
it's mate
so that's a problem
so yeah i don't think we should allow
our opponent
that much compensation that much um
game with queen g2 especially with
rookie one
yeah i don't want to see a way out of
this with queen c6
um maybe c3 to stop this idea of queen
c2 queen beats you to
do well checkmate so after rook takes
the error coming to c3
most likely take take
let's take that too um gotta take that
back
hoping for some checkmates but oh nope
that's not it all right
d2 i think this is still playable but
black definitely has the upper hand
so
yeah i think this is a yeah i don't like
this for white
so we should whatever we do we should
try to eliminate either this pawn or
defend this pawn
so i was thinking maybe f3 but even with
f3 i think um
i mean i actually do kind of like f3 you
can't really defend this even if you
play rookie two
um i'm just gonna take over here
now attacking both of these so this is
super winning
so i yeah this is not very desirable for
black
so i think f3 was a key move also
another
idea that we could work on was let's say
queen takes d3
queen takes g2 now our key one now
there's there are no more checks well
actually that's not correct there is
this check but queen f3
and or just f3 now if you try to simply
take my
rook um
what do you guys think about this
position do you think white is better
here
do you think black is better who do you
want to be
yeah i think white is actually exactly
good job guys white is better and
if black can't find anything super quick
then
black isn't a problem trouble so
yeah exactly that pawn is a baby queen
so yeah technically black would try and
take
but black's gonna run out of chicks soon
so this is something that um we could uh
well actually in the game i could try
and the problem was that
here i slightly chickened out and
instead of pushing for a5
to try and push for the queen i just
played f3
f3 is not a bad move it's like the
second best move
but the problem with f3 is that
psychologically you're showing your
opponent that
well you're kind of scared and you're
chickening out
also um you do you kind of you should
um you should always try to play for a
win and that's something that i say
and i've been trying to do in my own
games
but not necessarily um successful
in every single game but that's
something that i should have done
because
now after f3 what do you think what can
do what is um
what's the most annoying thing that
black could do
you did open a leeway for your king so
that's understandable
that is true two roofs would dominate a
rook in a bishop
but we kind of need to get those two
roofs in the game my rook on h1 is just
chilling for right now taking a nap
exactly so something between d3 or v8
those would be quite annoying right
i think d3 would be um the most accurate
one
because after d3 if i were to play
accurately and i played something like
a5 now let's say
um
kind of try to check king f1
and now this bishop is kind of monstrous
could get to d4
and dominate here too um
i was trying to see if there are any
dangers that maybe something with h5
so black could um
not worry about the back rank would be
rook a3
um rookie trains problem actually this
is good
uh who can't tell me what is wrong with
your k3
let's try and sharpen our tactical
skills too
um the problem was that if
before h5 if black played drunk e2
there it was rookie one and backrank
mate
so yes good job take on b2 and d2 check
nice one patrick so after take
um this is a huge problem you can't
really take that because well d2
um you could you can't really take on d3
because
actually i'm gonna keep asking why
because why do you think
this is so much better for black what do
you think is
the one move that
would make um white's position quite
miserable
so black to move what do you think black
should do
bishop c3 bishop c1 um
you guys are thinking about their
let me just tell you it's a it's quite
more sophisticated than just attacking a
queen
let me just tell you that
um it's something more about
if it's white to move white would try
and
run away with something like king king
you have to
put the king like maybe h2 try to go
like king g1
king h2 so we kind of have to stop that
thank you bishop bishop d4 is the best
one
taking away these squares the king also
can't go anywhere so the king is kind of
um struggling right so after bishop d4
black is actually
totally winning i can actually i can't
stop rookie three
i can't bring out this trick i might as
well toss this rook off the board
um if i play something like f4 so if you
play rookie three
i can try and play rook h3 that would
actually work but drug e3 is not the
best move
i can simply play rook to b8 and bring
this trick from the other side
right so yes
let's go a little bit back
that's why k3 is bad and let me go a
little bit
before two so in this position um ana
played rook e8
but she should have played d3 d3 would
have been the most accurate
uh she did play d3 a little after
playing rocky v8 but
after d3 i would be in big trouble
because after a5 now check
and some something just as simple as h5
because
if rook e2 now i would have a v1 ooh
maybe rook c1
try and go back rank it there
anyways uh my point being that this is
better for white
not winning but still much better due to
having the past pawns
um i assume our key one also works quite
nice
maybe bishop d4 again to take squares
away
because now we can't really take this i
mean we can
but um still you have problem with your
rook
now maybe bishop goes to try and dance
around a little
yeah it's not very pleasant
but anyways um so in this position
h5 is the best one and we just talked
about rook e3 and why this is bad
because the bishop d
bishop takes on b2 so what else do you
think we should do
maybe something like maybe d1 to go
after this guy
let's say we played this what do you
think is the best move for black
because if black doesn't play active and
gives
gives me like five moves i'm going to
take your d3 i'm going to get my king up
i'm going to
bring up the other rook and i'm going to
enjoy my
two pass pawns it is kind of a question
of coordination yeah
so what do you think black should do now
black has kind of like a
one best move
ah well it's good to know you've been
around watching the streams
pc um
you guys are kind of over thinking this
bishop d4
is interesting but the problem with
bishop d4 is that you're kind of losing
this now
so with the queen so no pins nothing
i'm gonna eat your pot no kidding so you
kind of have to be a little more
a little bit more tricky than that
exactly there is a free pawn um well not
this free palm because if you take queen
takes d5 i can just play a6 first and
you're still losing this
so no problem there um
but how about this other free pawn
what do you think we should do now in
this position as white
um well he could also take on h4 because
if i play queen d3 now then there's a
pop problem on rookie one checkmate
so we can't really take out d3 so taking
on h4 is like an indirect way of
protecting d3 so what do you think we
should do as white now
exactly queen d3 is a really bad move
so um g4 uh
not really sure about g4 actually
so g4 you do have a viable threat
that's interesting
what about i play g5 i still keep my
bishop here
yeah even now taking on h4 is a good
choice and yes
here taking on h4 is also the best
choice
and you can just take on here and you're
questioning your opponent do you want to
draw
because if king g1 there is a rookie one
so uh
best black could do is perpetual now
because well if black just gives me
three moves i'm gonna push push push and
make a queen so
all right um okay so what i was trying
to show you
uh this whole long line was
that d3 was the best move
and i also should be pushing for a5 i
should have pushed for a5
before f3 i should push for a5 any
chance i get and i didn't
i chickened out so this is the position
we ended up in she gave me check first
and then played d3 i got the chance to
play rook e1
i was pretty happy about that and
in this position she played bishop d4
check
what should we do what are you going to
do with your king
you have two choices g3 or f1 which one
do you think is better
and hint i did choose the best one
yeah g3 is the best one um
king f1 would the problem with kf1 is i
can just take this
or hold on what about rook e2
knife take take king over there maybe i
can try to
dance with the bishop we've seen this
position before
if take now there's this check
then there's that check yeah but this is
a perpetual anyways
um king f1 is not like a blunder but
it's definitely not the most accurate
one
so i played accurately i played qin g3
and after king g3 she
played rk8 and
what do you think we should do now keep
in mind this was a rapid game so by this
point we were both
in quite quite a huge time travel
and by
engines i have advantage
um i'm it was about
around plus two but this is not still
easy you still have to figure out what
to do with your position how you're
gonna
put your king in a safe position how are
you going to get rid of this pawn how
you're going to keep this pawn
how you get this workout so there are a
lot of
issues that's why you have to solve
um i should have played a5
so good one george a5 is the best one
because
we have to keep this pawn that's my
golden star
that's my golden soldier i guess i
should have kept it
and i thought that the safety of my king
and the activity of my rooks are more
important at that pawn
than that pawn and i kind of just gave
that up
without the fight i just played dirk d1
i thought directly one was a
very interesting move but what i missed
is rook takes a4
and the problem is that if i take on d
trina then there's bishop e5
i can't play king h3 because well you
see
bye bye mate so i would have to play um
king f2 and after king f2
queen c5 king e2
and that kind of ruins the whole flow
that we were having and putting the king
in the corner right
so um after rook 84
i only have one move to try and save my
position
because i made the mistake of
allowing the strip to activate and now
i've created a monster in the fourth
rank
so one move what do you think that move
is
i'm not going to give out any hints but
you already see
what happens if we take queen takes d3
no not from c1 but yes to f4 fun fact i
played rook c1 in the game
and that's how i lost
um i should have played f4 and because
this bishop e5
is a monster the problem was bishop e5
so i should have stopped that
so um
now perk c1 what do you think we should
do
what do you think black can do to kind
of wrap this game up
come on guys i know you can mate me
it's almost done i'm almost getting
mated just a few more moves
so what's the problem with c1 if you
move the queen i'm gonna meet you and
that will be very nice
but unfortunately anna was smarter than
that and did the bishop b5 check
only move king f2 now queen d4
check pretty much only move king back to
f1
and i was like uh my king was up here my
rook was about to be free
but um in this position
it's very important not to rush it even
when you can see that
black is doing much better you just have
to figure out
not to get over excited and
not blundermate and she didn't plunder
me she just played this h6
and i should have tried with something
like maybe
maybe g3 to try and get the king out but
this is also pretty hopeless
bishop takes g3 and even if i try king
up just
yeah it's still quite sad i've lost my
golden
golden boy my a4 pawn i'm losing my
exchange oh boy
so um in the game i simply play dirk d1
because i was still hopeful to get this
guy
unfortunately rook c4 i can't really
take here
because well guess what i'm gonna lose
this rook
so i went ahead and i played rookie
stream i was quite hopeful to get maybe
f4 to get to eat that but
after rook c2 queen e1
oh yeah rookie two and that is how
i lost to world champion nana muzichuk
still hurts to this day i had a
much better position so what we learned
from this game
is even when your position is beginning
to
look a little funky you can't think
about long castle you
you just because it's weird it doesn't
mean it's a bad move
back here when we were talking about
long castle should have done this long
castle
shouldn't have waited too long shouldn't
have tried to be too hopeful of getting
my kink to a safe spot in the king's
side
another thing that we've learned is not
to let go of our golden boys
too easily this guy was my golden boy
and i still miss him ah could have been
a beautiful queen
anyways uh i hope you guys had
fun with this game um
kind of painful for me but quite
educational hopefully
so um without much more comments i
am going to thank ben simon for the um
being the man behind the cameras well
technically behind a computer
and give the stream to var
don't go anywhere he'll be back shortly
and have